associer maison de retraite et accueille
des enfants en bas âge un concept qui ne
manque pas de charme bonsoir virginie
sans pitié vous êtes la présidente de
cette association les petits ateliers de
benjamin benjamin qui est bien avec vous
va voir sera sur un plan large dans un
instant benjamin voilà c'est un nounours
ans on n'a pas posé un enfant sur la
table mais attention à ce qu'on fait
depuis le mois de septembre avec la
quinzaine d'enfants de votre association
vous vous rendez à la maison de retraite
keita à montigny le bretonneux le jardin
d'enfants qui prend possession de
l'établissement on va voir tout à
l'heure comment ça fonctionne plus
concrètement qui on va en discuter mais
déjà cette idée vous vous l'avez vu
comment vous vous êtes inspiré de ce qui
se faisait aussi quelquefois dans le
reste de l'europe parce que c'est
novateur bwin en fait j'ai créé mon
association et je voulais faire une
association ouverte sur l'extérieur
donc j'ai cherché un petit peu ce qu'ils
avaient proche de beaux de bons domicile
en fait et avec la maison de retraite
donc j'ai contacté le directeur de la
maison de retraite en lui proposant des
rencontres intergénérationnelles
il m'a accueilli rapidement et de fil en
aiguille on en est arrivé à s'installer
physiquement dans les locaux de la
maison de retraite korian qui est à moi
c'est une fois par semaine on y va une
fois par semaine et des fois même un peu
plus puisque nous avons si la portée
musicale qui vient une fois par mois et
laurence contours du bibliobus qui
viennent ou lire des histoires aussi une
fois par mois voilà on va se rendre
justement à montigny on voit qu'elle
quand on voit quelques images mais on va
s'y rendre pour un reportage complet de
la rédaction on va voir comment ça
fonctionne et puis on va détailler
encore un petit peu plus après sur le
plateau du cette suite aujourd'hui jeudi
virginie champetier a créé en mai
dernier l'association les petits
ateliers de benjamin entouré de cinq
contres assistantes maternelles de 15
enfants de 2 mois à 3 ans virginie rend
visite chaque vendredi aux pensionnaires
de cette maison de retraite à montigny
le bretonneux
on veut produire que du bonheur en fait
est que les enfants y trouvent leur
compte aussi satisfaisant qu'on cherche
des activités qui soit bénéfique pour
les deux extrémités de la vie par
exemple il ya pas entendent à un loto
sonore avec les bruits des animaux donc
les personnes âgées aide les enfants à
reconnaître l'animal en fait donc ce
sont plus des activités comme celles ci
sont ainsi pendant une heure et demie
enfants et retraités partage des
activités ludiques
gisèle 85 ans ne manque jamais une
séance moi ça me convient beaucoup voir
que c'était du bien aux personnages et
de voir toute cette petite jeunesse et
tout ça c'est vrai ça mais ça redonne du
coeur sabella du baume au coeur et tout
ça c'est vrai je mens mieux quand je ne
vois pas comme je sais qu'ils viennent
et que je peux pas les besoins je les
attends elle a aujourd'hui j'avais prévu
je me suis bien préparé
avec l'association de virginie est les
seniors sont heureux de pouvoir passer
du temps avec les enfants qui leur
rappelle leur famille c'est important il
joue il ya une communication
on sent que des personnes qui commencent
à s'isoler quand il voit les enfants il
s'éveille ils discutent j'ai même le cas
d'une personne qui ne communiquait plus
et quand elle l'a vu les enfants elle
s'est mise à parler et une fois par mois
ils peuvent aussi se mettre à chanter
l'association de virginie champetier
propose des activités chorale des
enfants qui ont l'air de bien apprécier
un second rendez-vous le plus petit a
quel age 2 mois et demi sien est la
personne la plus âgée de la maison de
retraite 96-90 serbe a effectivement
c'est le grand écart pour ces rencontres
intergénérationnelles teckel quelques
détails sur le fonctionnement les
enfants qui participent mais uniquement
de la ville vient uniquement du quartier
comment quelles démarches et doivent
faire pour pouvoir justement s'inscrire
en fait nous sommes six assistantes
maternelles et nous allez les enfants
qui vont jardin d'enfants sur les
affronts que nous accueillons avec
l'accord des parents qui sont aussi
adhérent et qui participent aux
activités c'est à dire que l'association
lo ré ouvert et quand ils le souhaitent
ils peuvent venir participer un jardin
enfants la maison de retraite et
partager un instant avec nos fonds vous
avez la possibilité d'accueillir plus
d'enfants dans les prochains mois deux
dossiers pas spécialement notre souhaite
parce qu'il faut que ça reste convivial
et ça nous suffit à 16 ans puis c'est
super mais aussi parce qu'on imagine que
les liens entre les enfants et les
personnes âgées se durcit sauce hip hop
voilà le mois de septembre j'ai moi
j'accueillais 2 de nourrissons qui avait
juste quatre mois et de mois et une
semaine et aujourd'hui ils en ont
huit et six mois et les personnes âgées
ont vu qu'ils ont grandi les progrès
qu'ils ont fait pour ce qui est
intéressant c'est de venir sur du long
terme avec toujours les mêmes enfants et
ce que j'espère c'est que dans trois ans
quand ma is highly one sur le fond à la
maison c'est que moi sera toujours la
maison de retraite et les personnes
âgées les auront vu grandir
vous avez des anecdotes sur la façon
dont ça s'est passé des échanges
complète était difficile qui sont plus
facile maintenant ou des choses qui ont
été complétés surprenante
non tout s'est fait très naturellement
bah oui en fait on se moque pas question
qu'une surprise aussi bien de la part
des personnes âgées qui ont vu débarquer
tous ses petits enfants que des petits
enfants de se dire où là on s est pas le
cadre habituel de la maison vous n'en
les enfants c'est peut-être les adultes
qui ont un a priori sur les personnes
âgées et les enfants n'ont aucun il
évolua lorsque assez rigolo si par
exemple c'est ce qu'on imaginait que
monsieur morin quand on a écrit projet
qu'on l'a écrit vous avez un petit bout
de chou béquille comment ça s'est passé
à quatre pattes et qui s'accroche au
fauteuil roulant pour se mettre debout
qui est super content et en la personne
âgée qui est sur le fauteuil roulant
mais là encore plus contente en fait
voilà est ce que vous pouvez imaginer
toutes sortes d'activités parce que vous
avez mentionné biblio plus bibliobus on
l'a vu on chante et on danse est
également il ya des choses quelquefois
qu'il faut éviter de faire peut-être
pour respecter le calme aussi de la
maison de retraite
bruno ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'on
fasse du bruit alors c'est entendre rire
crier pleurer si des fois et c'est en
fait on leur apporte la vie et la vie
c'est tout ça et votre journaliste quand
elle m'a interviewé elle m'a dit oui
mais les enfants ne communique pas
est-ce qu'il faut savoir parler pour que
munich est en fait un sujet de
philosophie je veux dire non parce qu'en
fait ça passe à travers plein de choses
vous avez par exemple une toute petite
fille un bébé il va tripoter les mains
d'une personne âgée mec complètement
différentes des nôtres et ça c'est
magique ça va être suffisant pour créer
un lien direct et qui est déjà un voilà
ça a été difficile je veux convaincre
cette maison de retraite
absolument pas ils ont cru en moi ben je
remercie monsieur morin parce que dès le
début et sachant que je n'avais jamais
mis les pieds dans une maison de
retraite et jamais par les personnes qui
avaient plus de 80 ans peut-être
donc ça s'est fait en fait c'est
partager ses les ateliers de joie et du
bonheur et vous imaginez peut-être
étendre sa au reste de la ville avec
d'autres structures peut-être le
développer parce que l'objectif vaut
mieux qu'une maison de retraite dans la
ville avec d'autres communes parce que
vous l'avez dit au début l'objectif
c'était de sortir véritablement de ne
pas rester repliée sortir de sa valeur
après non je sais donner l'idée à
d'autres assistantes maternelles c'est à
dire qu'on a une disponibilité que les
écoles non
pas c'est à dire que monsieur morin avec
son adjointe avait beaucoup sollicité
les écoles ont déjà dont il faut écrire
un projet pédagogique long comme le bras
pour une séance par an sachant que nous
ses disponibilités on y va toutes les
semaines
et c'est ça et après c'est peut-être
donné l'idée à d'autres assistantes
maternelles pas envie de créer un jardin
d'enfants et qui sont qui sont sdf parce
qu'elle habite un petit village mais une
maison de retraite à côté croit pas
s'inspirer de vos réalisations
exactement six ateliers de benjamin va
créer un site sur lequel on va mettre
notre projet et pourquoi ne pas leur
donner les idées aussi vous d'aller
d'aller partager des bons des instants
avec les personnes âgées qui sont à
proximité de chez elle voit la part
bravo pour cette belle initiative les
petits ateliers de benjamin dont nous
parlions ce soir pour finir cette
semaine en direct du 7-8 demain 18
heures le vendredi ce sera à l'hebdo le
édition du week end avec catherine zula
toujours trouve lundi 18h pour un
nouveau direct nouveaux invités et bonne
soirée benjamin aussi vous a accompagné
ce soir